knows about seven and five on the year
but he's pitched very well against the
yankees you see at the bottom a
strikeout an inning he's got an
excellent change up
dj lemay who reached base in 32
consecutive games
a little looper into left field and
vernugo is right there to take it
rodriguez working from the third base
side of the rubber and his o2 pitch
finishes he has to get those hands
started so quickly
with that bat on his shoulder there and
it's not been working for
ruth ned or door now it's sharply but
the shift is going to work
and from somewhere near newton they
throw him out there's garrett
cole preparing for his 20th start and
if you think about a a pitching staff
having an ace
a horse a durable guy that you want to
win one game
there's your guy and now the yanks
bounced over him but taken by odor near
the second base bag and he throws
hernandez out
jaron duran got into the game last night
late as a pinch run
and he got him young mr duran meet mr
cole
and so it brings up the cleanup hitter
rafael devers
[Music]
about ready to go to the mount cole now
has questioned
about about three or four of porter's
calls on those borderline fastballs
[Music]
[Applause]
and the yankees have two on with nobody
out walk to sanchez single by torres
and it brings up brett gardner and a 2-2
pitch
parker slaps it toward left center field
this is going to get down
durant cuts it off on the warning track
one run is scored
gardner dives into second with an rbi
double the yankees are up one nothing
and torres is at third
rodriguez appears to be in some trouble
check out the follow-through
see he just he just kind of stands there
he doesn't really have all of his weight
and momentum going toward the plate and
then he feels down to that left hip
he's done yeah he's going to come out
wow
phillips valdez plenty of time to warm
up
valdez was with the red sox from opening
day through june 10th
but now you're facing greg allen with
great speed and the base is loaded
and doesn't valdez has faced three
hitters
fanned two of them hit the other with
the bases loaded the one-two pitch to le
mayhew
got him he faced four hitters he struck
three of them
jd martinez alex ferdugo and hunter
rinfrom in the bottom of the second
against garrett cole
and he makes very quick work of martinez
and he fans verdugo four out of six have
gone down
on strikes he's at first with two out
christian vasquez to the plate
fly ball to left center field
[Applause]
ryan lamar wants it and he takes it
stanton raced
odor aboard
and down goes sanchez his fourth
strikeout
as he faces taurez
running and he's out at second base
they've got speed on the bases in
hernandez and duran
full count one out bogarts not going
and bogarts is going back to the duggan
that's a perfect pitcher's pitch
now devers who went down looking in the
first again on three and two and he
struck him
phillips valdez is now in his longest
big league stint
this season and down goes taurus five
strikeouts already
in two and a third for valdez here's
brett gardner
and he gets gardner six strikeouts now
for valdez in two and two thirds
well seven strikeouts through three
innings
now hunter renfrow he had an infield
single in the second inning
and the foul ground goes kittens to
squeeze it
we go at second with two out now for
vasquez cole strike three
seventh k put of the book for call
youngsel rios out of the bullpen
after a very effective stint by phillips
valdez
the red sox bolt them not planned not
figured to be
uh strength certainly has been this year
well
over match there and sit down three
infielders on the right side against
odor
hit well to right back goes renfro back
to the wall
and has enough room bottom of the fifth
bobby dalbeck at the bottom of the red
sox order
dalbeck is caught looking on the 3-2
pitch eighth strikeout of the game for
garrett cole
single high off the monster and left by
hernandez long doubled by duran to rock
center bogarts has singled
and struck out looking and the o2 pitch
into right field it goes allen makes the
catch
hernandez tags heads for the play club's
play
[Applause]
25th home run of the season for rafael
nevers
and it's 3-1 red sox tradition there in
the grocery cart get a little ride
victory ride through the dugout
right-hander garrett whitlock
comes out of the bullpen fourth pitcher
tonight for the red sox
the mayhew goes the other way base hit
to right
renfro gets it back in and suddenly the
yankees have something going
and le mayhew has now reached base in 33
consecutive games greg allen a third and
dj lemay hewitt second it's up to
rudenetto door
odor swings on the first one pops it
into shallow center field
duran comes in and puts an end to the
yankee threat bobby dulbeck to lead it
off against nestor cortez jr a pair of
singles with one out
fernandez at second durant at first
bogart's at the plate
uncalled strike three and bogart spins
around
as if to contest it and then stalks away
[Applause]
as the red sox busted open two for the
night
26 for the season and another
cart ride for denver's jubilation in
aisle six
bradley makes solid contact on what a
play
with hernandez covering for the out
tremendous play
stretching his back afterwards red sox
doing it on in
all phases hitting pitching and then
bobby dalbeck with that
diving grab the last man between the red
sox
and their ninth victory in 11 outings
against the yankees
rudenetto door high fly ball left field
verdugo chasing it toward the corner and
he can't make the play
stanton is around third he's heading
home
oh door pulls up at second and it's a
six to two game
and the 2-2 pitch a high
pop-up who's
well the rafael devers show